foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
as I cut away the sides every so often
the snow will settle and just go it's a
nice little noise and scares the
bajeebies out of me
all right
thank you
foreign
this is a pretty cozy little shelter
I'll tell you what that is a beautiful
view
oh I've got room to sit down cook sleep
this is perfect and it only took me four
hours to make this thing which is a lot
less time than some of my other snow
shelters
foreign
oh this smells so good
a beautiful chicken mango Curry
oh that was good
foreign
[Music]
check for leaks and put the hot water
bottle at my sleeping bag get all nice
and toasty I'll tell you what this is
just one of the best snow shelters I've
ever made there's a couple key features
that are really important to keeping you
warm first off you don't want your
sleeping area to be the lowest point in
the shelter the cold air tends to
collect the bottom another thing is you
want to make sure your snow shelter has
lots of Corners you don't want to allow
the wind to blow straight into your snow
shelter additionally when you do have a
corner make a little extra room so that
the wind comes down it goes past the
door instead of being funneled into the
door
likewise on this end I've got two
entrances so that if the Wind Blows
crosswise the wind continues through the
shelter instead of getting funneled down
into the shelter but I'm gonna get a
chance to really test this shelter out
it's supposed to be a pretty good
snowstorm tonight we'll see what happens
looks like I had some sit on my face
the snow here is really soft hopefully
it'll freeze really good tonight then my
stairs won't fall apart the type of
quality of the snow really affects how
much energy it takes to build one of
these shelters this was really easy
stuff to work with so things went really
fast I moved a lot of snow in just four
hours the inside of this shelter is
about five feet wide and the roof is a
little bit over six feet tall so the
very back of the shelter to the mouth is
11 feet I had to move about 230 cubic
feet of snow to excavate this part of
the shelter so at the bottom of the
entrance to the top of the snow berm
it's a little over 10 feet deep but the
original surface of the snow was about
eight eight and a half feet deep the
distance from here at the top of the
stairs to the back of that wall is about
17 feet plus there's this little bit I
excavated right here so my rough
estimate is that I had to move about 423
cubic feet of snow to build this shelter
a little over 15 and a half cubic yards
that's the Max capacity of a commercial
dump truck I earned my hot chocolate
tonight
well it is getting late and it's getting
cold got some peanuts for a bedtime
snack
foreign
go ahead and eat some peanuts and listen
to an audiobook and go to bed but
tomorrow I'm going to do something
interesting I want to see what it takes
to make this tunnel collapse I know a
lot of people wondered whether or not
these snow caves will fall down on you
and honestly I don't know we'll test
that out tomorrow
oh good morning
oh I'm nice and warm oh yeah get up make
some breakfast
oh
oh look at this
got a lot of snow last night
oh yeah that's got to be at least a foot
consequently the roof is sagged a little
bit it's about an inch or two shorter
I'm having to hunch over a lot more than
I did last night snow caves will
actually do that they'll sag quite a bit
over time if you're going to use them
for more than one day often you have to
re-dig out the roof if you're a bit
claustrophobic you can make it hard to
sleep at night knowing that the roof is
slowly sagging over your face
all right let's see if I get my pants on
oh my pants are frozen
[Music]
steel cut oatmeal and sliced spam for
breakfast
[Applause]
all right the steel cut oatmeal is so
good got some butter in there brown
sugar raisins a little hot spam to go
with it
um
that's not bad at all all right why
don't we clean this place up and then
we're gonna go explore outside we got a
lot of snow out there
all right let's go see what it's like
outside
thank you
so proper little snowstorm up here it is
really snowing all of this fresh snow is
going to make the Avalanche danger go
through the roof luckily we're not in
any Avalanche zone so we'll be okay
above the ceiling right here the snow's
pretty thick but yesterday I could see
light shining through in that corner of
the cave which means there's less than
two feet of snow between the ceiling and
the surface of the snow you can kind of
see what I mean right here there's this
blue color that's light shining through
the snow right here you can see that's
about two feet of snow so I'm really
curious to see whether this roof can
stand up to 200 pounds of meat jumping
up and down on it
whatever
I couldn't feel any movement
yeah I mean it looks perfectly fine from
here well this one hasn't collapsed yet
but all snow caves collapse eventually
all right I think it's time to get out
of here
oh look how deep this snow is even with
my snowshoes it's going up to my kneecap
it's probably two and a half feet of
fresh snow since yesterday I got a
sneaky suspicion that my car might be
very stuck when I find it
I think I got some digging to do
yeah we got a good solid two feet of
snow I've got about a hundred yards of
unplowed road to go ah it's gonna be
tricky
oh
we've got absolutely no visibility don't
need visibility unless we can drive
somewhere
foreign
I got like 75 feet with that
let's dig it out and try it again
[Applause]
so I take my snowshoes and beat a path
to the plowed Road
oh that's a long way to go
foreign
I was giving it a bunch of throttle and
it just popped on me and I kind of
smelled this burning smell and now only
two of the wheels are spinning I think I
boogered up the all-wheel drive got a
gentleman in a big 4x4 pickup who might
be able to help get me out
[Music]
that's pretty sick
oh I'm about to go for a ride
oh we're doing it
all right man thank you
hey you too that pickup truck was a
monster if it wasn't for that I would
have been here for a long time
yeah
it does doesn't it
Oh Betsy not good well guys I made it
back safe and sound and hopefully you
guys enjoyed this video if you want to
see more Outdoor Adventures from the
outdoor Boys YouTube channel make sure
to click subscribe and put out new
videos every Saturday morning and check
out our playlist including our winter
camping playlist and our camping and
Adventure playlist all right guys see
you next Saturday if you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
Boys YouTube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this and
don't forget to click subscribe so you
can see other great videos every
Saturday morning hit that Bell button
you'll get notifications thanks for
watching
[Music]